euh moi aussi je les aime bien moi je
les aime bien
si nicolas
sarkozy
[Applaudissements]
je pense que c'est christophe landrin
garder les cheveux
à un peu de moi aussi de très loin par
fait un beau mais
ces pages et
102e photo deuxième photo voyons voir
bah oui bah oui bon ben là alors une
personne âgée
il est gênant ça que mon secteur voilà
la wii pour je peux être capable
de choses et sophie marceau
[Applaudissements]
cya
génial
vraiment au début on s'est vraiment
mettre le chroniqueur en valeur
sophie marceau
qui détaille serge il remarque c'est
ludivine intérêts qui m'a expliqué un
truc ludivine wade taquiner le mur rouge
dame
on m'a expliqué sa le les plus belles le
free nippon je suis totalement adeptes
voilà ce que seven s'est libéré le téton
sexualisé non mais c'est vrai qu'on dans
l'espace public puis on s'y habitue
aimons le sexualise c'est oui oui au
téton
[Applaudissements]
raison ils ont inversé on n'avait ni des
stars
tellement avec qui alors du coup ils
m'ont je
sais pas alors quelqu'un qui aurait
envie de vous dire à vous en faites
pas c'est guillaume en tennis
c'est quelqu'un de bien de ce qui est
bien non marc guillot
[Applaudissements]
ni contre je dois dire qu'en fait un
très beau coup et c'est vrai que ça a
été pour moi tout de suite une évidence
puisque c'est mon moteur comme moi
quand même belle je suis plutôt pas mal
et surtout ça s'avère que sophie koch tu
fais de la peinture oui et moi également
je me suis trouvé cette patiente depuis
dix ans à la peinture donc je me
retrouve tout à mes connaissances donc
un petit peu discernant parce que t'es
pas papa depuis trois cas de le dire
c'est bien connu
[Applaudissements]
anne et benoît
ainhoa
prénom se bat c'est le prénom d'un
village basque qui veut dire marie que
dira l'élu fait mon parti a les mains
c'est
franchement
la tête
généralement ttc on a
ces mois certaines je trouvais pas très
bien alors moi je vous explique moi les
accouchements gelé vite assez mal à vous
président vous êtes reste voilà donc
j'en dis que c'est lui qui est dans le
mon premier fils quand il est né c'était
vraiment c'était c'était c'était
halloween le le le
j'ai découvert parce que vous savez que
quand on accouche les médecins ils font
un truc que je ne connaissais pas y
mettre du paic citron pour que ça passe
mieux du service 5 sa guise legus avons
partout ça mousse et
on va avancer avec une photo floue alors
oui beaudet alors voilà comment daniel
moreau
visé c'est bien c'est beau mais que son
fils auquel personne non mais c'était un
homme alors c'est encore daniel
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il a
donc séduit tiennent la maintenance et
le voilà c'est officiel
d'une personne
à chaque fois je regarde avec mes
touches sentais que je ressentais des
trucs bizarres et un jour ma copine est
rentré chez moi et de ma grille en train
de regarder des replays sur mytf1
j'ai compris que j'avais des sentiments
ça va pas bien vous
allez on avance à la roudoudou
[Rires]
jason momoa
pour moi bah oui
mais quand même il peut tous fermés
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas vous ça passait pas tandis que
je méritais ah non je ne vous reconnais
pas si vous connaissez je ne reconnais
pas ma ma bon en même temps vous voyez
pas grand chose c'est vrai
[Musique]
on
a eu notre photo
baptisé lancé le site égérie de korriban
garder square est bon très bon joueur
très bons partisans
[Applaudissements]
c'est le type d'homme dix ans surtout
que c'est moins deux types de comptes en
banque en cas
c'est épouvantable photos suivantes i
roto suivante l'étau se resserre bat
sofia et son fils alors moi je dis qu'il
est plus jeune
c'est ou delphine quand il invite à peu
découvert tracées des allées bertrand où
ça peut être fière d'avoir un bon run
il est magnifique non certes il a à la
fois ce côté baroudeur et peut sauver
toutes les situations et il a le côté en
fait la manchette aussi j'aime bien mais
sa pleureuse est en danger parfois non
photo suivre ça va
donner sur bertrand
ça s'est su par une passe et elle fit
perdre et perfide balle en baisse et
elle adore les maillots donc eh oui
[Applaudissements]
le wall street il est juste mais
j'aime pas c'est pas gentil garçon en
guadeloupe non mais j'aime bien qu'on
suive enragé motos sont en avance bon
ben là
c'est qui
bah oui je sens que ça va être très bas
[Applaudissements]
alors sur le plateau c'est 50-50 des
princes du danemark et la robe et belges
pour le coup c'est bien là et la
coiffure c'est
que ces dernières photos
[Applaudissements]
nouvelle faute et
je ne suis pas une femme terminé samedi
si elle est très très belle
mare aux beats et c'est un canon voilà
écoutez moi tout ça restera au stade
puisque on a tous aucune chance d'être
non à part peut-être north appartenant
ou non rien